Missouri governor Eric Greitens says he
will resign on Friday he was considered
a rising star in the Republican Party
kryten's was hit by scandals stemming
from an extramarital affair alleged
blackmail and claims of campaign finance
violations Adriana Diaz is here with the
decision that followed months of debate
Adriana good morning good morning
accusations that Greitens had an affair
with a woman he blackmailed with a
partially nude photo became public in
January
since then the former Rhodes Scholar and
Navy SEAL has been fighting to stay in
office while facing a growing number of
calls from fellow Republicans to resign
the last few months have been incredibly
difficult for me for my family
Missouri governor Eric Greitens did not
admit to any wrongdoing as he announced
his resignation Tuesday saying the quote
ordeal has caused incredible strain for
his family it's clear that for the
forces that oppose us there is no end in
sight Greitens faced a felony charge for
invasion of privacy for taking the photo
of a partially nude woman without her
consent but the charge was later
dismissed in April he was charged with
another felony alleging he raised money
for his campaign by misusing a donor
list for my charity he founded and just
two weeks ago the Missouri legislature
convened a special session to consider
disciplinary action against the governor
I know and people of good faith know
that I am not perfect but I have not
broken any laws nor committed any
offense worthy of this treatment fellow
Missouri Republicans called for Greitens
to step down some feared his possible
impeachment could hurt the party's
chances in a tight Senate race against
incumbent Democrat Claire McCaskill
Republican state representative Jean
Evans I was actually relieved I feel
like this is really the right step for
the people of Missouri senator roy Blunt
who stopped short of calling for
Greitens to resign said in a statement
the governor made the best decision for
his family and the state starting Friday
Republican lieutenant governor Mike
parson will serve as governor as for the
criminal charges against Greitens
the local st. Louis prosecutor says her
office has reached a
fair and just resolution and we'll
release details later today so we'll see
alright Adriana Thanks